tracy is putting out decorative bowls of
potpourri in each room of the hotel
where she works she wants to fill each
bowl with one-fifth of a can of
potpourri
if tracy has four cans of potpourri in
how many rooms can she place a bowl of
potpourri
so she has four cans and she wants to
divide these four cans into groups of a
fifth of a can so if you have four or
something and you're trying to divide it
into groups of a certain amount you
would divide by that amount per group
so you want to divide
you want to divide four
by one fifth you want to divide four
cans of potpourri into groups of
one-fifth so let's visualize this
so let me draw
let me draw one can of potpourri right
over here so one can of potpourri can
clearly be cut up into five fifths
we have it right over here one two three
four five so one can
one can of potpourri can fill five bowls
if you put a fifth in each bowl now we
have four cans we have four cans let me
paste these so two
three
and four
so how many total bowls of potpourri can
can tracy fill
well she's got four cans
so this is going to be equal to let me
do this in the right color this is going
to be equal to once again she has four
cans
and then for each of those cans she can
fill five bowls of potpourri because
each bowl only requires a fifth of those
cans so this is going to be the same
thing as four
times
four times five or we can even write
this as four times five over one five is
the same thing as five over one which is
the same thing as four times five
four
times five
which of course is equal to which is
equal to
20. she can fill 20
cans or i should say she with her four
cans she can fill 20 bowls of potpourri
now just as a review here we already see
we've already seen that dividing by a
number is equal to multiplying by its
reciprocal and we see that right over
here dividing by one-fifth is the same
thing as multiplying by the reciprocal
of one-fifth which is five over one so
we got she can fill up twenty bowls of
potpourri